Whether you're unclear as to how all the pieces
of Netflix's new hit show Locke & Key fit
together, you want answers to some of its
bigger questions, or you're simply hankering
for some hints as to where season two might
head… this is what you need to know.
First thing's first: At the end of the day,
Dodge won.
Dodge's real goal wasn't stealing the Omega
Key.
It was opening the Black Door.
She didn't need the Omega Key to accomplish
that.
She simply had to trick Tyler, Kinsey, and
Bode into opening the door for her… which
they do, despite Kinsey's eventual better
judgment.
"Does this feel right to you?"
"If you have any better ideas, I'm all ears."
"Best available idea doesn't make something
a good idea."
Dodge's scheme isn't shown on screen chronologically,
so here's roughly how it works: First, Dodge
uses the Identity Key to transform Ellie into,
well…
Dodge.
Then she straight-up knocks her out.
Next, Dodge uses the Crown of Shadows to summon
an army and leads an attack on Keyhouse.
While the stakes feel real, they're not.
Dodge intends to let the kids win.
Then she drops Ellie's body, disguised as
her own, where the children can find it.
In order to dispose of Dodge for good, Tyler,
Kinsey, and Bode need to put her back in the
Wellhouse.
Unfortunately, no one knows where Ellie hid
the Echo Key, so instead, the kids decide
to open the Black Door using the Omega Key
and dump Dodge inside.
See where this is going?
The children and their friends throw Ellie's
disguised body through the portal even as
one of Dodge's demonic peers escape.
Dodge's biggest threat, Ellie, is gone, her
other enemies think she's no longer part of
the equation, and now she has an equally powerful
and hungry partner in crime to help out.
The Lockes think they won, but Dodge got everything
she wanted.
Of course, getting rid of Ellie and opening
the Black Door isn't the only way that Dodge
has set herself up for success in season two.
As the final moments of Locke & Key's first
season reveal, she's also earned Kinsey's
trust and her heart by using the Identity
Key to masquerade as Gabe, a member of Kinsey's
friend group.
As the season-closing montage implies, Dodge
has been masquerading as Gabe since the very
beginning.
It was Dodge in the lobster suit.
It was Dodge who tortured Eden using the Music
Box Key.
It was Dodge who stole Kinsey away from Scot.
That tracks.
Gabe doesn't appear until after Bode gives
Dodge the Anywhere Key in the first episode,
and his pitch-perfect emotional manipulation
of Kinsey always felt a little predatory.
The Dodge-Gabe deception echoes one of the
graphic novel's main plotlines, although it
works a little differently in the book.
The Identity Key doesn't exist in the comics.
Instead, Dodge uses the super straightforwardly
named Gender Key to switch between her male
and female forms.
Masquerading as a boy named Zack, the male
Dodge who looks exactly like Ellie's old boyfriend,
Lucas becomes Tyler's best friend and Kinsey's
boyfriend.
Expect something similar to follow in season
two.
Still, it's not like Tyler, Kinsey, and Bode
ended Locke & Key season one on a completely
down note.
While they might've been duped into a false
sense of security, they did grow immensely
thanks to their adventures in Keyhouse, and
were finally able to get over the death of
their dad, Rendell Locke.
When Locke & Key begins, Tyler blames himself
for Rendell's murder.
When Tyler's former classmate, Sam Lesser,
makes a crack about offing his father, Tyler
jokingly asks Sam to kill Rendell, too.
When Sam actually does murder Rendell, Tyler
can't help but feel responsible.
Meanwhile, Kinsey can't forgive herself for
being too afraid to fight Sam during the attack.
Ultimately, Bode's trauma is a lot more simple:
He just misses his dad.
"I wanna see my dad… please."
However, after Sam visits Keyhouse and reveals
that he's in league with Dodge, Tyler realizes
that Rendell's death had nothing to do with
him.
Kinsey copes with her shame by literally dragging
her fear from her head and trying to kill
it.
She only forgives herself once Tyler points
out that she wasn't able to stop Sam because
she was too busy protecting Bode.
The youngest Locke sibling is now connected
to Rendell's legacy through Keyhouse and the
magic keys, which Rendell also used as a boy.
The loss of Rendell will always be a big factor
in the kids' lives, but as the season concludes,
they're also, finally, able to move forward.
"Your house is filled with amazing keys.
There's a key that can let you step outside
your body and be a ghost…"
"Whoa!"
"...And another that can change the way you
look."
One big mystery that Locke & Key's first season
leaves hanging is the keys' true nature.
We know they're magic, but why are they in
Keyhouse, and where did they come from?
If Locke & Key continues to stick to the comic
books' mythology, we can find the answer there,
too: Quite simply, the keys are made out of
the bodies of the Children of Leng a race
of demons straight out of H.P.
Lovecraft's playbook and were forged by the
Lockes' ancestors in order to control the
forces beyond the Black Door.
In the comics, when a Child of Leng comes
out of the Black Door, they don't just die
when they fail to find a host.
They actually turn into a substance known
as Whispering Iron.
When Benjamin Locke discovered the Black Door
during the Revolutionary War, he quickly realized
how dangerous it was and used the Whispering
Iron to make the Omega Key, keeping the door
shut.
Benjamin went on to make a number of other
keys, which he hid around Keyhouse for later
generations to find.
Again, later seasons of the Netflix show might
retcon or streamline this history a little
bit, but the show's been faithful so far.
It doesn't seem likely to change too much.
Even for comic book readers, it's hard to
tell exactly where Netflix's Locke & Key is
headed.
The first season burned through lots of the
comics' major plot points at a pretty rapid
pace, leaving the future very murky.
Still, there are a few things we know.
We haven't seen all of Keyhouse's magic keys.
Without giving too much away, keys like the
Animal Key, the Angel Key, the Owl Key, and
the Giant Key will look great on screen and
should be lots of fun.
Duncan, the kids' friendly uncle, has very
little to do in season one, but plays a much
bigger role as the story progresses and if
you think Dodge is finished with Bode, just
wait.
The little guy is in for a very, very rough
time.
The show also raises new questions that the
comics never dealt with.
Kinsey's fear is attacking her classmates.
How will the kids stop it?
Ellie isn't dead, she's just trapped beyond
the Black Door.
Is her time on the show done, or will she
find a way back through?
There are a lot of loose ends to tie up.
Season two can't get here soon enough.
Until then…
"Aloha!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.